understood what's happening
and we can get into why that is i think
a lot of people that you and i would
normally agree with people who are
anti-establishment on both left and
right have called this completely wrong
and we can talk about why that's
happened as well so yeah i think that
there's a lot to talk about but
obviously
i should probably say at the start as
well i think it's an easy uh thing for
people to assume as you know i have
russian-speaking family in ukraine
some of them are pro-russian some of
them are pro-ukrainian
but i really i i'm not really that
interested in having this conversation
from the point of view of like what's
best for constantine's family
because i don't think that's what people
in the west care about or should care
about i think what we should talk about
is what is the right thing for us to do
here in the west
and why this has happened okay well
before we get into all of that so let's
go back a couple of weeks because
there's a lot of people probably
watching woken up
seen this and thought how the hell has
this happened so let's go through it
right from the to start two weeks ago
well i think to start it two weeks ago
would be to misunderstand the nature of
what's happened i think we have to go
back to 2014
uh which is when russia first invaded
ukraine uh this has already happened so
it annexed the crimean peninsula which
is in the south of ukraine and it also
started what was a sort of low-level
civil war uh in the eastern parts of
ukraine in the donetsk and lugansk
regions which is the eastern part of
ukraine
and at that moment in time
the reaction from the west was well how
can i put it diplomatically pathetic
there were some very weak sanctions
there were some words of condemnation uh
russia was kicked out of the g8 which
you didn't really care about uh and that
was it and so i think what what the
people who run that country learned was
we can do this
with impunity
and so a few weeks ago what happened is
russia started
amassing troops on the border of ukraine
and a couple of days ago vladimir putin
made a speech
which i think we really need to talk
about in length to to to help people
understand
why no one's told them what's coming
even though it was immediately obvious
and and we know exactly what's coming
now as well because it's obvious from
what he said right it just hasn't been
covered in western media i don't
understand why uh so he amassed these
troops on the border a couple of weeks
ago uh people in the west started
warning about it a lot of people started
saying well this is just saber-rattling
it's a distraction uh what we need to do
is just say to putin look ukraine's not
going to donate if you remember we had
this big argument with nigel farage
about this on our channel
um but that was it was obvious to me
from the beginning that that was never
going to be the way it was going to go
for reasons that i'm sure we'll get into
okay so but why does putin have this
fascination with ukraine why does it go
back to 2014 why did he want to annex
the crimea because surely that's an
anti-antagonistic gesture that means
that he he the sanctions will then be
imposed on russia that will weaken the
russian economy and by doing that
doesn't he weaken his position as leader
well no he strengthens his position as
leader because he's not he's not
answerable to people here in the west is
answerable to the russian population and
to russian people expanding the borders
of russia is seen as a great thing if
you remember this was the case uh here
in the uk and in america only 40 or 50
years ago if you think about margaret
thatcher she was saved by the falklands
war right this was a war about an island
off the coast of argentina which we won
which exactly uh so this idea that the
greatness of your country matters uh is
something that's been lost in the west
but everywhere else expanding your
borders are seen as a great thing now as
to your question why there's an invasion
now and why putin is expanding into into
uh ukraine uh he explained all of this
in that speech and this is i think the
right time that we should just break
down what he said it was an
extraordinary thing i don't think anyone
in the west has ever seen anything like
it this was a president of a country who
spent an hour
on national television talking about
history
the first 40 minutes of a speech he
talks about the history of russia and
the history of ukraine
and his argument essentially is that the
existence of ukraine
is a historic mistake it should never
have existed uh the existence of ukraine
is the result of a series of weak
decisions made by various soviet leaders
starting with vladimir lenin and then
nikita khrushchev and others
and uh the the mistake as he sees it is
that the russian people
the russian nation
uh which was embodied in the soviet
union he was artificially split up
and
a portion of the russian nation was put
together with what he called pieces of
former poland and hungary and put
together into one country which became
ukraine so in his view ukraine is a
mistake it shouldn't exist
uh he claims uh in that speech and also
in uh the speech that he gave this
morning
uh
essentially justifying the invasion that
russian speakers and ethnic russians in
ukraine are being genocided i'm not
exaggerating this is the word he used he
says there's a genocide happening is
there a genocide happening
i mean my family live in in southern and
eastern ukraine and their russian
speakers i if there was a genocide
happening i think i'd probably find out
about it
um
but
it doesn't really matter what the truth
is what matters is
what people believe right and if this is
what he believes
then you know that's one issue and if
he's just saying this in order to
justify an invasion that's another issue
both are bad and we can get into that
but
so the first thing to say is he
explained that essentially the russian
nation was split up a piece of poland
and hungary and other countries was
glued onto a piece of russia and made
into a country and these are historic
mistakes that
he he says a sort of understandable and
difficult time that the country was in
at the time but we cannot be held by
decisions made at that time
by weak leaders who made these weak
decisions so the first thing that you
should know um this is why the invasion
was always going to happen because he's
essentially explained that the ukraine
ukraine shouldn't exist
he explained why it shouldn't exist he
explained the historical reasons um he
also
uh was he also made some other points
along these lines which is essentially
that
the russia after the collapse of the
soviet union
took on the the all of the entire soviet
debt and it paid it off and left as he
sees it to ukraine and other countries
of the former soviet union this great
russian inheritance the land that
russian people had conquered over
centuries the
the great technological achievements the
manufacturing the the shipbuilding all
of that so one of the points he makes as
you said look in ukraine in one of the
southern ports they've just shut down a
shipbuilding
yard
which was the foundations of which were
laid by catherine the gray
the russian
tsar or tyrion or whatever you call her
in english so what he's saying is we the
russians we gave you this stuff
we gave you this great culture this land
these technological advancements and and
you've squandered them
he talks he spends 10 minutes talking
about how russia is corrupt and not
russia sorry
ukraine is corrupt how it's run by
oligarchs how um
is that true
of course it's true of course it's true
but the same is true of russia of course
it is right all of that world is run by
oligarchs and is corrupt i mean would
you say that the western world is not
run by oligarchs and is not corrupt it
is right
every country to some extent is run by
oligarchs does that the question is does
that
justify their neighbor invading that
country and taking over that's really
the conversation we're having so um he
he talks a lot about how uh you know
ukrainian education is poor and people
are not looked after and the pensions
are not great and gas prices have gone
up and how terrible things are for
people in ukraine uh so that's the
second part of this speech
um which is so the first part is
explaining why ukraine shouldn't exist
the second part is explaining why people
in ukraine are suffering particularly
russian people and russian
speakers in ukraine are suffering and
the third part of the speech and this is
the final part of the speech and i don't
understand why it hasn't been reported
on i mean the first few parts are
important because they tell you
everything that's going to happen right
if you don't believe ukraine exists and
you believe it is your historic mission
to save the people in ukraine who are of
russian ethnicity or russian speakers uh
from being abused by ukrainian oligarchs
you always knew there was going to be an
invasion and you always knew it was
never going to be limited to those two
regions because when he talks about well
you've you've glued on parts of poland
and parts of hungary onto ukraine onto
this russian peace
that means that at least half of ukraine
including the capital kiev
is within the strike zone of what he
wants to achieve
right there's no question about that so
the invasion will not stop in those two
regions in the east unless it is stopped
somehow by the west which at this point
is looking unlikely but his intentions
are not to stop with those two eastern
regions there's no question about that
anyone who tells you otherwise either
doesn't understand or wants it not to be
true or whatever but those are the facts
right he is going to invade
uh as much as he is allowed to and he
wants to invade at least up to kievan
probably beyond
just on in terms of that part of it the
third part of it and the rationale for
his
uh
invasion
is that he says that
the west is meddling in the affairs of
ukraine the west is meddling in the
affairs of other eastern european
countries the west is expanding nato uh
which he says they say is a defensive
alliance but actually this is a way of
putting rockets and missiles and he goes
through all the different rockets and
missiles that the west already has and
is developing um
to they want to put them all around
russia so that they could strike at the
heart of russia any moment so he is
literally saying that ukraine is
planning an offensive against these
eastern regions uh which you know some
people in ukraine are joking and going
yeah we waited until putin had 200 000
troops on the border and then we were
like hey let's let's do an aggressive
action here
and uh the other
thing that he says is essentially the
west is about to attack i mean he he he
doesn't mince words about it he
literally says that he says the west is
getting ready it's putting nuclear and
other sort of missiles in position to
strike against us
and we must defend ourselves now
how you defend yourself by moving your
borders closer to nato i don't really
understand but that is the argument
and the there's an argument there that
that nigel put forward is that the west
in particular america has been
antagonistic
with putting these missiles
these
missile placements around the russian
border and actually if they've been a
little bit more considerate this
wouldn't have happened do you agree with
that
i think it's impossible to know i don't
personally agree with that uh i i think
you uh
when i say you i mean i think people in
the west
forget
the personal dimensions of this uh
you've got to understand that um
this paranoia about the west has always
been a feature of the russian mindset um
it's
it's not something that
is going away
and
uh if
you could say well look if the west had
just stayed out of it everything will be
fine that isn't true i mean the same way
that ukraine is being invaded now
estonia latvia lithuania
uh these are countries that have
russian-speaking minorities uh that can
be weaponized in exactly the same way as
the the one in ukraine is
uh these are countries that used to be
part of the soviet empire after they
were conquered and annexed by stalin
while the europe was busy with with
hitler
stalin took all of eastern europe
basically for himself including those
countries
um so uh no russia was always going to
try and expand and this is what people
in the west really don't understand is
this isn't about nato being aggressive
causing it it's the west being weak
that's causing it the reason vladimir
putin is doing this is he knows that the
west is divided the west is distracted
the west spends more time talking about
pronouns than it does about things that
matter
and
he's taken advantage of it just like the
chinese i see people want to make this
all about vladimir putin's this evil guy
and he's going crazy
he's not he's not crazy he's doing
exactly what any sane leader in his
position would do
just like xi jinping is doing that in
china you see the west as weak you do
the things you've been planning to do
for a long time
that being the case so we've got that
that expansion into ukraine he's
actually come out and been quite
aggressive to the west and saying you
know if the west gets involved they i i
can't remember his exact words put it
this way he wasn't being friendly
what in your opinion do you think the
west should do now
it depends on you know it's like people
keep asking me this question and if you
remember i said this to nigel farage it
depends what people in the west want
it's like that scene in alice in
wonderland where alice meets the
cheshire cat
and she says well
would you tell me please where i ought
to go from here and the cat says well
that depends on where you want to get to
and alice says well i don't mind where i
get to and the cat says well then it
doesn't matter where you go
what do you want
what what do people in the west want
i think well
i think if they're being honest they
want this problem to go away you don't
want peace yeah oh that's very easy
it's very easy just surrender
that's the way you get peace
so if if we surrender then he takes over
ukraine and then he takes over latvia
and estonia and lithuania and czech
republic and hungary but no one dies
and but you can't keep doing that you
can't just let
nato countries because lithuania isn't
how does that impact on nato because
surely the nato agreement means that
once a country gets invaded then their
fellow allies come in to protect them
but nato's over i mean this shows you
that nato's over people uh you know when
we talk about those people go well
you know uh i don't want to go and die
in ukraine like i was talking to my wife
my wife's ukrainian you know uh this
morning and she was saying well i really
hope the west does something you know
they need to be strong and i'm like yeah
i agree with you but you know you're
seven months pregnant you want me to go
and fight in ukraine
she's like no do you well if you don't
want your husband to go and die in
ukraine whose husband should go and die
in ukraine
whose son should go and die in ukraine
no one no one wants to no one in the
west wants to go and die in ukraine
right
uh so that's but ukraine's not part of
nato right but this is why i'm saying
nato is over
okay let's say he invades ukraine we
protest we put sanctions in place
whatever he invades lithuania
what is that different you want to go
and die and fight in lithuania but
surely the agreement surely the
agreement with nato changes something
doesn't it
what changes what do you want to go and
die in lithuania
no do you want british troops to be in
lithuania fighting against russians
no does anyone in america want american
troops on the ground in lithuania no no
nato is over
and
looking at the america uh the
presidential situation in america with
biden you and i have been quite open
about the fact that we both think biden
has been a disaster if you look at what
happened with afghanistan
well this wouldn't have happened if it
wasn't for afghanistan yeah you
understand this right right let's go
into that why do you say that
well
look francis you and i have spent our
uh
career so far in terms of trigonometry
focusing essentially on one thing we
talk about different things with
different people but we've been trying
to explain to people
me as a first-generation russian
immigrant and you someone who comes from
partly from venezuela yeah who's seen
that world we've been trying to explain
to people in the west one very simple
thing
which is
if you destroy your own civilization
from the inside
you the punishment is coming
that's what we've been trying to do
right we've been trying to tell people
that if you spend your life worrying
about this comedian who made the wrong
joke or uh this you know our men women
or our men or which bathrooms do we use
if you spend your whole life worrying
about things that happened 400 years ago
that were done by people who may look
something like you against people who
look like those people over there
you're going to be distracted from the
business of
of reality
you know this is one of the reasons i'm
actually somewhat optimistic today
if there's one note for optimism it's
this we've been living in the dream
world all of us in the west
and
i hope that the wool has been lifted
from people's eyes somewhat we don't
live in this magical world of diversity
equality and [ __ ] gender non-binary
[ __ ] you don't think putin has pronouns
in his bible probably doesn't
we don't live in that world we live in a
world that operates on a very simple
basis which is power strength land
military right that's the world xi
jinping and vladimir putin aren't
worried about how to maintain peace in
the international community they're
worried about doing what they think is
the best thing for their country and
until people in america and people in
the uk understand that it's our job
to think in the same way to defend our
values to remember what they [ __ ] are
we've been talking about this for four
years man
if you approach a random person on the
british or american street and satan
what are british or american values
they'd run away from you like you're
trying to recruit them into the [ __ ]
edl
no one knows what they are and people
are terrified of defending them defining
them let alone defending them
so
we are where we are in terms of that
where are you with the argument and
we'll come back to that in a second but
where are you with the argument trump
made an announcement
quite like him saying under my watch
this never would have happened do you
agree with that of course
why
you know donald you you would have had a
teacher like this at your school
somebody that you didn't quite know what
to expect from them so you didn't [ __ ]
with them just in case
that's donald trump yeah
that's donald trump
and he understood the way the world
actually works he was not a nice guy
he was he didn't write nice things on
twitter
he didn't take losing very well
you you know he said some things that i
don't agree with
but
the the job of your president or your
prime minister is to go out there and
get the best possible deal for your
country not to write nice things on
twitter not to be friendly and polite to
achieve the best possible outcome for
america
the job of our prime minister in this
country is to go out there and achieve
the best possible outcome for british
people
donald trump for all his flaws did try
to do that
and it's funny because in the western
world he was despised and he was not
respected in the rest of the world
he was respected people feared him
people respected him and they'd known
they knew not to [ __ ] with them
so do you think as well
trump would have approached this very
much like a businessman and he would
have said to putin look
let's reframe this
how can we work with you in order that
we can make ourselves richer
instead of doing the more kind of the
democrat approach which has been
effectively to make themselves absent
from the world stage do nothing and
watch the whole world go nuts as a
result because there's a vacuum of power
look we're getting into very big
hypotheticals now i don't know what
trump would have done i just don't think
that this would have happened if you'd
been in power uh i think things would
have gone very differently i don't think
there would be an invasion of of ukraine
i don't think china would be expanding
in the way that it's expanding or
dealing with
uh some of the issues they're dealing
with in the way that they were
um we we have an absence of leadership
uh it's it's interesting i was talking
to my uncle in ukraine yesterday and i
was saying to him well look
you know we're i'm thinking of you and i
wish you all the best and all of that
uh and he was saying look you know we
have we have hope here uh because you
know uh boris johnson has been really
good
and i was like you're [ __ ] then aren't
you
there's an absence of leadership man
look you and i have spent again years
talking about this the caliber of
of western politicians
i mean it's pathetic
you know nigel farage when he was on the
show he made this joke about liz trust
some woman who's become foreign
secretary and he's right she went over
to russia she didn't even
she didn't even know
russian geography
and these are the people that are
negotiating on our behalf with you know
you can make your criticisms of vladimir
putin the one thing i would not ever say
about him he's not a stupid man no
he's not a stupid man and the people
that he chooses to work with him are not
stupid people xi jinping is not a stupid
man and the people that work for him are
not stupid people
you know the people who are there and
i'm not saying list trust is foreign
secretary because of diversity i'm just
talking about the broader context here
you know if you choose the best people
you're going to end up with the best
people and if you choose people based on
what looks right and what sounds right
and who's never said the wrong thing and
who's never made an offensive joke and
all of that you're gonna end up with
small people
people who who never say or have an
original thought people who are afraid
to express themselves openly people who
are afraid to call a spade to spade i
mean this is why
people hated trump because in many
things you just said it like it is
like ordinary people think it is yeah
you know for example people got upset
about his comp comments about mexicans
and and something about how some of them
are rapists and blah blah blah well to a
lot of ordinary people when they see a
mass wave of illegal immigration coming
over the border they know for a fact
that some of those people are criminals
right so when everyone had this massive
uh you know falling out over that i was
like well
that that's true you know
that's not to say that all mexicans are
bad people which is what people made it
mean but that's not what he was saying
at all he was talking in a way that
people process the world
and let's go back to the war in iraq
yeah a complete disaster yeah awful
awful awful never should have got
involved
how much does that affect u.s policy and
uk policy to this day massively this is
why you and i opposed it so vehemently
at the time uh what the west has done is
undermined its own its own moral
authority and it has none anymore uh and
that's why you see a lot of the people
like i say that you and i would normally
agree with
essentially
refusing to understand what's happening
and refusing to understand that that
speech that vladimir putin gave
he was talking
it was a cold war speech
that's how people used to talk during
the cold war
they are about to launch nuclear
missiles on us so we must get ready
that's how people used to talk and
that's what he said we are in a cold war
and a lot of people fail to understand
that because our moral authority to say
we are the west we believe that our
culture is the best culture for us at
least and we're going to defend it we're
not going to let other people challenge
us we want to be the dominant superpower
in the world because we understand that
that is how we protect our way of life
no one wants to say that anymore why
because iraq because syria because libya
because all of these afghanistan all of
these places that we've gone in
completely
unnecessarily often on based on
completely
made-up reasons
killed thousands and thousands of people
created isis right empowered the taliban
now they have more blackhawk helicopters
than the uk military right
people are rightly looking at that and
going well now they're telling me about
this place called ukraine that i've
never seen on a map you know isn't it
just one of them
unfortunately it isn't
it isn't one of them this this is
this is existential for the west this is
uh you know today is the sudan land
situation uh we're letting putin do what
hitler did in 1938 which is take a chunk
of land that he claims is populated by
ethnic russians
and he's not gonna stop that and he's
not and you can see him continually
moving in well as i explained he he
explained why ukraine should not exist
and why he's justified to go in there
and sort it out because it's so wrong
and bad there's quite a lot of
ukrainians who support putin aren't
there as well uh i no i don't think
there's a lot of ukrainians to support
peace and there are some for sure
there's no question about that like for
my own family for example they're
members of my family who are celebrating
really yeah
this is what they always wanted right
and there are members of my family who
are crying
it's it's a very complicated situation
there are people who who support uh that
i think they're in a minority
and
when we talked with mikhail svetov
he said that the west has turned russia
but particularly putin into a bogeyman
he said
we almost see him as sort of this
cartoonist character
we don't know a lot about him who
actually is he what is his background
and how did he actually get to power
because i think that's also very
important in this conversation okay well
this this ties into another part of the
conversation which is about
what russia is today uh a lot of people
in the west i think think russia is some
kind of sort of quasi democracy maybe
just a democracy right because they keep
having elections yep right he smashes
them as well yeah he does very well
surprisingly
so uh russia has never had a single
democratic transition of power in its
entire history ever
ever there's never been a time when
power has passed from one president to
another in a normal transparent
democratic way
where the democrats have handed power
over to the republicans the tories have
handed power over to labor that has
never happened
in the entire history of russia
democratically so when the soviet union
collapsed boris yeltsin became president
after what was effectively an overthrow
of the government
right
uh he was president for for about eight
years
uh and then what he needed to do was he
needed to find somebody who was not
already part of the power structures
somebody who was not already uh a
politician because anyone who already
had any measure of power the moment uh
boris yeltsin left they would take away
all the money that he'd stolen they
would deprive him of all his possession
they probably put him in prison for the
crimes that he'd committed etc
and so they needed boris yeltsin needed
to find someone who was an outsider to
whom he could give the power and say
look here is all the power that you've
ever dreamed of and all the money that
you've ever dreamed of and in exchange
you let me live out my life and peace
and that's what happened what he did is
he appointed this guy that nobody had
ever heard of called vladimir putin
who who uh we'll get into his background
in a second uh he appointed him prime
minister
uh not president but prime minister uh
acting prime minister for a period of
time uh during which he uh basically
picked them up and then at some point he
said look my health's not very good
i'm going to take a step back and let
this young man take over and look after
the country until the next election and
then at the next election the people can
choose whoever they want right
and of course once putin became acting
president in this way
he was always going to win the election
because he had been set up to do it
then he became president he was
president for several terms
when his constitutional right to remain
president ended
they did a switcheroo he did exactly the
same thing that boris yeltsin did with
him with dimitri medvedev you remember
him
barely probably and so medvedev became
president and putin became prime
minister
as they swapped around and during the
medved of presidency the constitution
was amended
to allow vladimir putin to serve more
terms and longer terms
and they swept swapped background
immediately afterwards so putin then
became president again so vladimir putin
we are sitting here in february 2022 he
has been in power in russia since 1999.
wow
you think about what the greatest music
hits were at that time what would they
be
anton
greatest music it's from 1999 probably
something like probably oasis would be
right so think about this we were all
worried about the millennium bug yeah
when putin came to power wow
and he's been in power since
now as to his background he is the
former head of the kgb if you don't know
what uh therefore be the kgb uh they are
the successor to the secret police of
the soviet union which was the chika the
the emergency committee
if you say to any russian that someone
is a chiquist someone comes from the
special services
uh there it immediately makes it clear
who these people are um
essentially the the kgb with the
the equivalent of the gestapo
in nazi germany so
they are the people who the secret
police who would torture people who
would put them in prison who would put
them in concentration camps uh who
organized mass murders
and unlike in nazi germany where the
gestapo and all elements of the ngati
machine were eradicated
that's not happened in the soviet union
or in russia in particular at all uh the
prisons are still there they still use
the same prisons that they used to use
in the 30s and 40s to to murder and
torture people so
the the people who run russia are the
ideological successors to the russian
gestapo wow so that's who you've got and
you can actually that makes a lot of
sense then when you look at his modus
operandi for dealing with people who he
feels have betrayed him or enemies or
his enemies in that the poisoning that's
completely out of the spy playbook yeah
absolutely
so
what
when
looking at that type of man in charge
what shouldn't have been always obvious
to the west that they were dealing with
a malevolent force that this was someone
who didn't have good intentions this was
someone who they needed to have a strong
hand with this is somebody they
shouldn't have let just
behave how we want it
yeah but but look at us now
we're doing the same thing yeah like i
said who
like you can say oh vladimir putin's a
really bad guy and we really can well
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
yeah and it's also as well how much
influence is russian money
which is being invested in the city of
london which you know you look at all
these wealthy russian people you know
you've got our politicians wives playing
tennis with their wives
how much of that of an effect does that
have on our decision making against
russia well nobody knows exactly but
it's obviously no secret that there's a
lot of russian money be swimming around
london the city of london in particular
a lot of lawyers and bankers and the
state agents of all the good people all
the great people uh all the moral people
they've they've all you know got fat and
rich off of that of those criminal
proceeds um
that's absolutely the case but i think i
don't think it's about that i think
that's part of it i think uh the reason
germany so pathetic on this issue is
that they've made themselves hostage to
russia's
gas supplies uh when they shut down all
their nuclear reactors purely on
ideological basis uh as as we are trying
to do in the rest of the west and with
this green shed that is going on uh
we're making ourselves energy dependent
on our strategic adversary uh we're
you're literally giving you're going hey
we've got a weak spot here you can stick
your knife right right there uh and so
yeah
but but the bigger thing is is the one
that we've already talked about which is
this is about the west being unwilling
to assert itself
more than anything else and what impact
do you think is that going to have on
china because china are obviously going
to be watching this what do you think
they're going to be doing well xi
jinping is wanking himself dry isn't he
i want an image that i mean i think he's
a bit old for that i don't know i don't
know i think he's going to be that
excited this morning that he might be
look if you're in china and you're
watching this
you're going great like i i'm surprised
they haven't invaded taiwan yet um
when would be a better time to invade
taiwan than today
is there a better day to do it no
so it's probably coming as well
do you think that this will
fundamentally change the way the us does
international relations i think this is
this today was fundamentally going to
change the world
this is a 9 11 moment
probably bigger than 9 11 in some ways
in terms of the impact it will have on
the world well
because that's a big statement to make
because look what 9 11 what happened
with 9 11.
the war in afghanistan yeah which lasted
forever how long 20 odd years
okay we then had air travel which
changed forever yeah
i'm glad you're going for the big things
for me yeah yeah well it was a bit
they're making me give up my war yeah
and my shoes take off my shoes you know
all warren and iraq all of these
different things international terrorism
yeah the right islamism yeah yeah
you think that this moment is going to
be bigger than that
i do yeah i mean i don't see how it
couldn't be
how could it not be we're in cold war
we are in a cold war too with russia
okay so what does cold war mean to you
cold war means that we stop pretending
uh as vladimir putin has already done
stop pretending that we live in a world
of international trade and peace and all
we want is to all grow and you know sing
so the end of globalization complete end
of globalization a lot of countries are
going to recognize now that energy
security is vital
there there's going to be an
understanding that you know an
international supply chain that relies
on uh russian oil and gas and chinese
manufacturing isn't going to work
so you're going to see
probably more a more internal focus in
terms of strength strength strengthening
in the west and and the things that
we're doing you're probably going to see
proxy wars all over the place as you did
during the days of the cold war you know
vietnam south korea korea all of that
those were all basically struggles
between the soviet union and america
funded and you know often supported and
often you know manned by soviet and
american soldiers
um
you're going to see the world change
completely uh the the global order that
we've had since 1945 the idea of which
was look there's some [ __ ] weirdos
over there who are uncivilized and
primitive and living in the 18th century
and the rest of us here in the civilized
world we're going to make peace and and
trade and be happy that's over now
it's over but
what would you say to those people who
think you know the conspiracy theorists
who say this is all rather convenient
our economies are not doing very well
after covid we've got a huge deficit
inflation is going through the roof what
we need is a good war
to get us back on an even keel
financially well wars don't get you on
an even kill financially they they
bankrupt you so that that argument
doesn't make much sense to me so that
argument doesn't make much sense it's
fair enough
i think that the conspiracy stuff that
maybe you are thinking about is people
are saying this is biden has
orchestrated this um in order to look
good by diffusing it well
first of all i never bought that i
thought that was a moronic thing to say
but even if even if it was well he's
he's not done very well is he no yes
defusing it but that's really not what
this is about i think this is one of the
reasons um
you know i find
the last few days very humbling actually
because i've watched
a lot of people that i normally agree
with about things to do with the culture
and the culture war and so on
really embarrass themselves very badly
and it's made me realize that i really
ought to refrain from commenting on
things i don't understand and the list
of those things is very large this is
one of the reasons you and i both start
stopped doing
panel shows on gb news uh because we
felt that we were being asked to have
opinions about stuff that we we weren't
qualified to to have an opinion about
and a lot of people are really
embarrassing themselves at the moment
because
they they are reacting instinctively to
their pre-existing conceptions of how
the world is but they don't really know
anything about russia or ukraine they
don't speak the language they've never
been there they don't understand the
history they haven't watched vladimir
putin's speeches they haven't looked at
any of the documents to do with
everything that's going on
it's just their perception
and you know that i am the number one
critic of the mainstream media in this
country and in the west but it's their
perception that the media keeps lying to
them which it does and therefore
anything the media says is then
automatically not true
well
that isn't the case the the fact that
the media reported something doesn't
mean it's not true it means you have to
be skeptical about the way it's being
presented and you have to look deeper
and i've made my own criticisms right at
the beginning of this discussion about
what the media failed to explain to
people in this country but just because
the media lied to you about this or that
doesn't mean that this particular issue
isn't what they're telling you uh
they're not telling you the full picture
because they don't understand the full
picture themselves this is what people
don't get about television and the media
it's run by kids yeah
if you go into a tv studio the people
running it in their 20s
they couldn't find ukraine on a map
they don't know what's going on
they're just reacting to things that
they're being told by people who they
think are experts but they're not even
qualified to decide who's an expert or
not
that's the media isn't some massive
manipulative machine
it's it's a bunch of people who don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing
with a few people turning the knobs at
different ends to make sure that it kind
of presents the right message
for them
but it's not there's no grand conspiracy
in the media to misrepresent stuff they
just have a certain world view and it
bleeds into everything uh it's not the
same as some kind of evil conspiracy
that they couldn't organize a conspiracy
if they tried
we've said it's it's a death of
globalization and we've been making
predictions about that have proven to be
correct
what is going to happen do you think so
you've said that this is the end of nato
how do you think this is going to affect
the eu when i say the end of nato i'm
not saying nato is like going to
dissolve tomorrow yeah but what i'm
saying is nato is not going to be
willing to defend its easternmost
members yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
which means as a defensive organization
nato is over it's it's finished which
was its primary purpose yeah that's what
it's created yeah so what about these
other globalist structures like the eu
for instance do you think that
the eu is going to be fundamentally
affected by what's happening when you
look at the fact that germany
gets mo gets the majority of its power
from russia
what are the germans going to do how is
the eu gonna because if they compromise
aren't they
they are they are compromised i mean
they're also terrified
because lithuania estonia latvia poland
these are all countries that are members
of the eu
so i think people in new york starting
to wake up this is why i'm saying the
world is going to change very rapidly
now
because they're going to realize they
can't pretend anymore
you know just like all of us i think
realizing you can't pretend anymore we
like i said earlier we've been living in
a dream world
men or men or women or women or what or
like
when when there are men on your borders
with guns that sort of like idea of oh
maybe you know toxic masculinity like
that's gonna
fall by the wayside somewhat i think
so with with with the eu no one knows
exactly what's going to happen they've
actually been surprisingly vocal about
uh what's happening um i think you know
there's other people in europe who
understand the historical parallels here
and
do you feel that this could be because
what this is
at the moment for me it's it's a fork in
the road for our civilization for the
west where we want to where we want to
go you said you were you were quite
positive about it do you think that this
is a moment where we could
it could be a reinvigoration for the
west in that we need an enemy we need
somebody to push back against we need
something to focus the mind
look
that is obviously a very cynical and
pragmatic way of looking at it and for
someone who has family who are you know
crying on the phone and there's
bombshells you know landing
in their cities now obviously
that sounds an incredibly cynical
way of looking at it
because people are going to die
many people are going to die it's going
to be awful
we are going to come closer to nuclear
war than we have been for 60 years do
you think that there's going to be
before we get back into it do you think
there's going to be a sustained fight
back from the ukrainians we don't know
it remains to be seen i mean i was
you know the the problem in 2014 for
ukrainians was um it's interesting i was
talking to my uncle about this and he
was saying well look the problem in 2014
was how do we shoot
at the russians
and i was like oh so you didn't have
enough weapons and he was like no no the
question for us was how do we these are
our brothers we used to be in the same
country we are the same people
look we want our own country we want to
be independent but we are the same
people
how can we shoot
our own brothers and sisters
he said that problem isn't a problem
anymore really
that problem isn't a problem anymore
but that doesn't mean that ukraine and
its military won't immediately collapse
either because
uh
that there's a you know
in almost every war the
the human factor is the deciding factor
and if if you consider yourself from the
position of a ukrainian
kid who's 20 years old he's been
conscripted to fight
you know
is this a war you're going to win
probably not so why would you risk your
life
why would you try your hardest why would
you
you know
it's
it it could go that way as well
um so it could be that ukraine puts up a
really strong fight and and develops a
sense of national resilience with
western support with western weaponry
etc
uh or you know it there could be a lot
of units that just don't want to fight
that could also happen
it's very interesting that you say that
because there have been notable examples
right the way through history where a
smaller country has triumphed over a
bigger country particularly when they're
being invaded yeah and when they're
being supported yeah yeah yeah it could
happen uh like i say i i don't that that
is not something that anyone can can
tell you what's going to happen and do
you think the west are going to start i
mean they've already put sanctions in
place yeah do you think that they're
actually going to start to bring in
troops no
no the west is never going to put troops
in ukraine
why not
because then you're starting world war
iii
but surely if you bring in troops that's
a sign that no more
so when you say bring in troops what do
you mean so for instance put them where
and what do you do with them right so
essentially i mean this is where i
expose my lack of military knowledge
but
wherever the russian line is you bring
troops to face them and say no you will
not come what you're saying is basically
putin's going to invade the power
ukraine he's going to invade
and then will the west then put its
peacekeeping force on that board yeah
no i don't think it will
no i don't think it will
do you think it will
no
there you go no i don't i don't
do you think there will be supplying
arms to the influence they already are
they already are
but
the the problem that i have with this is
the problem that you've identified
the weaker that we are the weaker the
the more that we show that we are weak
the greater
the advantages that putin is going to
take yeah
there's going to be a time where you've
got to say enough
surely there's got to be a time yeah
yeah
and i'm worried when will that time be
you're not making me feel good mike i'm
sorry
i have nothing but truth to offer you
you're right
you're right the the
the
as long as the wek the west continues to
be weak
these problems are going to multiply
and even if
you know what what is likely to happen
i'm not saying this is exactly what will
happen because at this moment in time we
don't know exactly what's going to
happen
but what is likely to happen is
putin is going to invade the part of
ukraine that he wants
the west will introduce strong sanctions
and offer strong military support to
ukraine uh
putin will say look we've got what we
wanted that's it we're not expanding
anymore we've whatever and this
situation will die down
and then in 2024 when trump runs again
and everyone starts to have another
meltdown
he will then encroach again
because this is what you do
you wait until your enemy is distracted
and then you act
so
uh this is the beginning this isn't the
end this is the very beginning and this
is what people in the west really need
to understand this isn't about ukraine
this is not about ukraine
this is about you
it's about your children it's about
their future it's about the world you're
going to live in because the fundamental
thing and you know you and your
girlfriend have a lot of arguments about
this because she's a massive
anti-imperialist lefty
this is what these people don't
understand is yes the west is evil
it absolutely is evil
and the things that america and britain
do in foreign policy are wrong and bad
and evil they are who who could dispute
that who could argue that the war in
iraq was just and fair and decent who
could argue that what we've done in
afghanistan was the right thing
who can argue that destabilizing syria
and destroying libya as a country
they're creating isis who could argue
that any of that is good or moral or
just or right
nobody i i certainly wouldn't i opposed
all of those things
but the question you always have to ask
yourself is
who would you rather the world was run
by
the evil imperialist americans
or the wonderful russians or the
wonderful chinese
that's the choice there is no
unicorns and rainbows option
you can be run by [ __ ] of different
colors which ones you want to be run by
that's it
and that's what we have to choose if you
want to be run by russia great well just
remember if you're a woman for example
we care really about women's rights here
in the west in russia it's not illegal
to beat your wife
it's not illegal it's been
decriminalized
you can beat your wife in china if
you're a muslim weega they're going to
put you in a concentration camp they're
going to cut your kidneys out and sell
them to the west as donors for donors
that's what they're going to do you want
to be run by those people
the people who have concentration camps
today
you want to be around by russian who do
you want to be who do you want the world
to be right is going to be run by
someone
you need to pick a team
yeah
we've got a few more minutes and then we
will be taking your questions so if
you've got questions to us put in a
super chat and then we will probably do
about another half an hour so make sure
to put your super chats in now if you
haven't done so already and ask
constantine questions and then i will be
your fielding your questions to
constantine now what do you think of the
argument that
putin has become increasingly more
paranoid
as
he's gotten older
because there have been several attempts
on his life he's become ever more
isolated and these are just the actions
of a man
who is no longer i'm trying because i
don't want to get poisoned either
of a man who's slowly losing his grip
shall we just say
i i don't know the answer to that
question i don't know him personally and
one of the things i've learned from our
experiences of being in the public eye
some in some way is you don't you know
what people write about me online isn't
who i am
and the same way with vladimir putin to
the nth degree so there are two
possibilities i would say uh about
his mental state um both are bad but one
is worse than the other uh one of them
uh is that he uh
he is simply
operating on the hitler playbook which
is to say that
he wants to rebuild the the nation
and attach parts of what used to be
germany what used to be russia back
together that's what the sudan land was
all about
um
this was land taken from germany
populated to some extent by germans
right the same here and he's using all
of these excuses and making things up
about genocide of russians and all of
that in exactly the same way that hitler
did
to take land
that is the better option
if he's just an expansionist
authoritarian who wants to take land
from neighbors while the west is looking
the other way
in order to enrich himself and his
country yeah and to maintain his
leadership etc that is a sort of fairly
normal pragmatic thing to do right he
doesn't have a racial and animus in the
way that hitler did so he's probably
going to conquer a few more countries
and do we know where he stands on the
trans debate i think we do man it's
pretty hardcore on our side on that one
we agree with vladimir putin on the
trans debate uh
that'd be the title of the episode
exactly but so that's
one option the other option is the one
that you describe which is he actually
believes that the west is about to drop
nukes on moscow and he actually believes
that ukraine was about to invade and he
actually believes
all the paranoia that he expressed in
that speech
in which case
yeah i mean
we are in a very serious cold war period
uh that
may
not even end with him going whenever
that happens and he looks like he's in
good shape so it could be it could be a
while
um
because what that then means is we're
locked in this cold war standoff because
it doesn't really matter what you know
if you said to someone here in the west
you know russia the west is about to
launch a missile attack on russia they'd
look at you like you were mental but if
people in russia believe that
then it doesn't matter what the truth is
about western intentions all that
matters is they believe that and then we
have to deal with that
so i mean to say that was it the daily
mirror who had i think it was on their
front page what would happen to london
if there was a nuclear strike yeah and
they said this is the area that will be
ruined yeah i mean it's a bit of a weak
word
yes yeah you know nagasaki and hiroshima
they were ruined
and you just look looking at going
it seems that we've been talking about
things that don't matter for a very long
time yes
it's naught to 60 in the space of a
couple of seconds it feels i know it
feels that way but you've got to
remember i've been predicting this for
years i've been saying this is what i've
been saying
for years
the what weaker the west is the more
other people are going to come into that
vacuum and take over this isn't new this
has been happening for decades the
western elites that we talk on the show
about about wokeness and all of that
there's a mind virus that has spread
into their brains that means that
they're not capable of focusing on the
things that matter and this has been
going on for decades they're teaching
people to hate the west they're teaching
people to hate this country they're
teaching people to hate our values and
how can you possibly defend values that
you despise
why would you fight for democracy if you
think democracy is evil why would you
defend our liberal capitalist system if
you think it's evil
do you
where would you be
because there's a lot of people who and
the particularly academics i remember we
went to an economics and uh
conference a few years back and every
debate that i saw at the position that
every academic took was like this is the
end of the empire and we should just
accept manage decline yeah yeah and this
is where we are and there's nothing you
can do yeah
where do you stand on that well i think
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
um this is one of the reasons that uh
trump was so hated
he refused to buy into this paradigm
if you think about his election slogan
what was it make america great again
what does he mean by that
he means no [ __ ] decline yeah we're
not going to give up our top dog status
we are going to fight tooth and nail to
maintain our supremacy in the world
that's what you're saying and people in
the west are deeply uncomfortable with
that message
do you think that if president putin
walked out onto the steps of the kremlin
and gave a speech to the red square
saying we want russia to be the richest
most powerful most dominant country in
the world
to maintain its status as as it
currently is the biggest country in the
world we want the russian people and the
russian language to be spoken around the
world do you think people would be like
oh my god i can't believe you said that
why so nationalistic
people would be cheering
imagine if donald trump or boris johnson
came out and when
our job as americans is to make sure
that america is the most powerful
country in the world and that no one
[ __ ] with us
what would happen on twitter
what would happen oh they're going to
meltdown
so there you go
that's it
if america and britain and western
europe refused to defend their right
to be the most powerful people in the
world
what that's it isn't part of the problem
as well and this is a final question
there's a helicopter over here
yeah don't worry just wait for the sound
of missiles um isn't part of the problem
as well is the fact that we're a
democracy we don't have a case yes that
is a big problem we must change it
immediately
that we don't have a continuance
continuancy of leadership yeah all of
the decisions we make are short-termists
yeah because we think in four year or
five years no we don't no we're done
we think in 24 hours
the prime minister of this country and
the president of the united states are
not thinking about a year from now or
four years from now or the next election
they're thinking about the headlines
tomorrow
that's what they're thinking about so
yeah of course it's a problem we don't
have any strategic thinking
um
and the people who make these terrible
mistakes are never going to be held
accountable for them
ever i mean look at iraq yeah if tony
blair was the leader of an african
country he'd be at the hague
if zimbabwe had invaded egypt let's say
or bombed egypt or destabilized the
country on the other side of the african
continent
that person would be at the
hague is tony blair is george bush no no
because we don't hold ourselves
to account for those things and that's
how we've devalued that's how we've
taken away our own moral authority to
act in situations where action is needed
i mean it's been an uplifting chat
no i'm just telling you how i see it man
yeah there's nothing else i can do i
mean
look i am more positive today than i
have been for a very long time
because to me
the decline and collapse of the west
has been inevitable
for
since i've started really paying
attention
and there is a small chance
that what has happened today will lift
the wall from people's eyes and we stop
living in the dream world and we
recognize that we've got to stop wasting
our time on things that don't matter and
start to go back to some very sensible
ideas about
right and wrong about who we are as
people about what we believe and
remember
look geopolitics is just a competition
that's all that it is and if you don't
want to fight and you don't want to play
in that game someone else is going to
play and fight in that game instead of
you that's it
uh so
if this is the shot in the arm that
western civilization needed then i'm
hopeful uh if it's not the west is over
going to see what happens but you are
hopeful
more hopeful than i've been for a long
time yeah
so not that hopeful no
well uh we are now gonna start answering
your questions so if you've got
questions for constantine like i said
before
hit us up with some super chats and we
will pick out the best ones we're gonna
do it about half an hour
and we'll be putting your questions to
constantin sir anton can you make sure
that you've sent me
uh all of the questions please have you
sent them on the telegram
yeah you're going to send me guys give
us a second we're going to go through
stuff this is the first time we're doing
a live broadcast of any kind uh like
this so uh just bear with us while
francis and anton get stuff ready if
you've got questions send them in if
you've if you've got any comments if
there's anything that uh sparked any
sort of discussion uh put that in the
chat and we'll see how much we can get
through in the next half an hour
so uh there is a first question is
absolutely cracking it's from icky ike
and he says
how do nuclear weapons weigh into this
strategically we still have the threat
of mutual annihilation
do you think russia will use nukes in
ukraine no
i don't
no
no i don't
i don't think he would i don't think he
will use nuclear weapons no this isn't
about that he's not he's not kim jong-un
he's not a madman yeah like i say he he
actually is pretty sane and rational and
most other people who would be in power
in russia today would be doing the same
thing i don't think it will use nixon
ukraine now okay so ikea you got the
answer to your question right now as
depressing as you were hoping
yeah he's i want the end of the world
now
this is from dean cosgrove
and he says how telling is it that many
people who emigrated to the west from
countries like china and russia have
been warning and overall against the
nonsense the west has been arguing with
the culture war
so of course i mean all of us see it we
we're not able to pretend like you guys
that nothing's happening because we know
that we understand how these people work
um we understand see people in the west
live under a number of delusions
and one of them is that everyone in the
world
wants what we want and thinks the way we
think
they [ __ ] don't
they don't
what the taliban don't
what we want but but this is what people
think yeah people in the west can't
understand
someone who is extremely religiously
motivated for example who is so
religiously motivated they're willing to
blow themselves up in the name of a
cause
the very few people in the west who
would do anything
in the name of religion like that right
and in the same way people in the west
don't understand why a country might
want to expand its borders
they don't yeah they don't get it
but people in the rest of the world do
understand that because let me put it
very simply and crudely for you people
in the rest of the world want what you
have
they want what you have the prosperity
the freedom the stability the the
democracy they want all of that
but mainly the prosperity they want to
be the top dog in the world
they want to have the most money per
head of population in the world they
want the comforts they want to be able
to throw away the food that we throw
away that's what they want
and until they have it they're always
going to want it
that's it
there's no there's no other there's no
other
there's no other great secret to it
people in the rest of the world want to
be as rich and as successful as people
in the west that's why immigrants like
me come here and that's why countries
like china and russia are doing
everything they can to expand their land
to expand their power to expand their
influence and to expand their economy
that's what they want
not about diversity francis i'm sorry is
it not no it's not it really isn't
it's about some pretty hardcore fairly
sort of old-school things
that human beings have always known
great question right let's move on and
let's see what else we have got so we've
got uh
ikkyok has sent another one he says why
did you wake me up at 4am
to tell you the truth icky ike to tell
you the [ __ ] truth
uh
so this is from irish pandy he goes i
have only one question why didn't the
west let russia into the eu union and be
part of nathan nato when he offered the
hand of friendship
russia doesn't make sense as part of
nato and it wasn't a hand of friendship
russia russia doesn't belong in nato
it's a country with a different cultural
mindset and it wants different things
russia doesn't want to be part of the eu
not really
and it wouldn't work russia can be
integrated into the eu in the way that a
cancer tumor can be integrated into the
human body
it's it's not the same thing people in
poland and in latvia and lithuania they
want to get the hell away from that sort
of old-school authoritarian way of doing
things
people in russia don't want that and the
russian leadership don't want that they
want to maintain
essentially a dictatorship
that's what they want more than anything
else i'm not saying every single person
in russia does but they're very
comfortable with that way of governance
they're not trying to get away from this
soviet past they're embracing it whereas
what the rest of eastern europe has done
is trying to move away from that so
russia doesn't belong in nato and
doesn't belong to you it's a different
culture
yeah with different ideas about politics
about the world about how things should
be
alex alexander uh asks uh do you support
immediate western military intervention
no i don't because as i said i think
that would start world war three do you
really think it's that extreme well if
you start fighting russia with the
british soldiers what do you think is
going to happen
that is world war three
that's what happened in in that's how
world war ii started
hitler invaded poland and britain and
france said well we have an obligation
to support ili
we're going to come to their defense
we're going to fight and that started
world war ii so if if the west sends
military
troops now that is starting world war
three so i don't support that no
[Music]
okay thank you very much
let's see this is from colby hamilton
uh who says the only necessary for the
triumph of evil is for good men to do
nothing
correct
now i don't like framing it in terms of
good and bad because it suggests that we
are somehow impure pure and perfect and
vladimir putin and people around him are
evil i i don't believe that for a moment
and colby is a christian i'm sure would
agree with me that every human being
is complicated um i don't think the west
or we should look at this as a is a
matter of good versus evil i think we
should look at it in a much more sort of
darwinian pragmatic term it's it's a
matter of
us versus them
it doesn't matter who is right or who's
wrong
that's not how they are going to be
thinking about this and that's not how
we should be thinking about this
someone's coming
they're coming for our top dog position
in the world
i know and russia and this is what it
looks like see when people talked about
oh well you know this acidity is trapped
and china is going to slowly become
no no it's not going to be chinese
people are more rich than us
50 years from that's not what it's going
to look like
it's going to look like this it's going
to look like taiwan
it's going to look like ukraine
lithuania latvia's tonya
if the power of the west wanes
the west is going to shrink and the east
is going to grow that's what's going to
happen and before you know it
you're going to be living
under you know
a very different regime to the one that
you're used to
gemma asked a question which uh
did cross my mind in the initial
interview
what is the likelihood do you think that
putin will be overthrown by the
oligarchs or do you think
zero zero why
at this point look it could happen at
some point then he has complete control
he spent 20 years cleaning out anyone
who's against them
the people who are
below him all
uh owe their status and power to him
he could have any of them removed or
killed at any moment
um i
don't see this happening
the only way that he might be removed
in the long run and this will take time
is if
very strong sanctions are applied of the
kind that britain i don't think would
ever apply
and they
hurt the oligarchs very badly
and also then hurt the people of russia
very badly who become
restless now i'll push back on that but
surely if he starts encroaching more and
more yeah those sanctions are going to
become ever more strict okay well let me
give you an example
so one of the sanctions would be to
seize the assets
of all russian oligarchs
in the west
with the media effect
to bar
the children of russian oligarchs from
going to british boarding schools
would you do that
it depends how extreme the situation is
does it
you want to punish russian children
for the actions of vladimir putin i mean
but that's what sanctions are
effectively that's what you do you do
punish russia as coming from a country
where my mom does which has had
sanctions that is what happens what
would you say about that
well that is true but
sanctions always punish the most
vulnerable they're not going to pass but
when when it's being done over there and
you're not seeing the children starving
to death that's one thing what about
these kids right here right here in the
uk
are you who's going to sign up to that
that's the only way is if the people of
russia see that this strategy is really
not paying off and if the oligarchs
around putin really feel
the buy
they lose all their money which by the
way
most of their money is in the west you
understand this so why don't they just
freeze bank accounts well not freeze c's
yeah seize bank accounts
they have frozen some bank accounts
but if you want to have an impact you
would seize those bank accounts and give
that money to ukraine to fight the war
yeah
but you don't think that's going to
happen no i don't
i don't think people in the west have
the stomach for it
even
if he starts marching eastwards towards
or westwards towards lithuania again
we're getting into a hypothetical right
okay like yep
i take your point so we have got
uh
zathra says uh thank you constantin for
speaking sp sense about different
mentalities in russia rest of eastern
europe poland and the west keep on
speaking sense
uh
he says uh
let's have we've got former guest
of of the show francis ball who says i
must be one of few right-wing immigrants
but what west doesn't understand
is that not all brown people are
left-leaning cut the white savior
complex so i don't think it is the
francis ball was on it was another
francis ball but going back to that
point of about how
we're spoiled in the west really we
don't understand how good we've got it
we're soft we're not used to fighting
we're not used to confrontation and all
of a sudden now we have a confrontation
we don't really know what to do
and also our lives are infinitely more
valuable than they've ever been
we live longer yeah we live more
fulfilled not fulfilled but sort of
materially satisfied lives yeah you know
uh so
you know if your life expectancy is 40
and your life's pretty [ __ ]
and you you go off and there's a rigid
class system which prevents you ever
from advancing then maybe going off to
war
coming back as a hero
and achieving something and being able
to get out of your class limitations
that does explain why the scots are so
violent yeah exactly uh that may be a
new route out for you but if you're
going to live to 85
and die of covered or with covet yeah um
and your life's pretty great why would
you go and risk that you're risking way
more than you would have done in the
past yeah uh rich richie 77 uh has got
some sort of mental illness he says
constantine for prime minister yeah yeah
let's not do that
if there's one thing that west really
doesn't need as me as prime minister
yeah so we've got amy vows uh she says
came in late again so not sure if you
covered this
but how worried should we be in the west
about cyber attacks from russia very
worried
well we haven't talked about that
because i don't know enough about it so
let's talk about it uh it is
perfectly possible that in response to
strong sanctions uh russia will
retaliate and one of the most obvious
ways is to attack uh you know internet
infrastructure and all of that so as
somebody who is a complete luddite
explain to me what does that actually
mean if the internet stops working
that's what that means and your phone
reception stops working
really and your electricity grid goes
down
that's what that means
and do you think that that is in his
playbook it's a possibility for sure
yeah
yeah absolutely
if the sanctions against russia
uh are perceived as being by him as
punitive and whatever he could try to do
that but our job is not to shy away from
that our job is to make sure our
defenses are secure um
that's interesting and i i don't know
enough do you know enough about that
well i i was talking to one of our
former guests who doesn't know enough
about it who's dr pippa malngram who
advised two years presence i was on the
phone with her yesterday and this is
what she was saying like a lot of the
shenanigans are going to be of that
nature really yeah
so it's not actually going to be direct
conflict no there's going to be direct
conflict in ukraine yeah but in terms of
the west that is a possibility
yeah
so we're going to be seeing more and
more of that type of action yeah
so very interesting uh
let's have uh anton by the way are you
checking the pay pals as well no
okay we might have those let me have a
look at those right
let's see so we've got
a very
interesting article uh interesting
question here
we is the person we normally refer to on
raw as barry
he says how much does the bidens joe and
hunter dirty dealings in ukraine
complicate the west dealing with this
now i.e motors of the white house not to
be trusted or untrustworthy
i don't know enough about it
instinctively i'm tempted to say it's
irrelevant
but i don't know enough about it okay
sorry barry sorry barry apologies mate
the reason i'm instinctively sort of uh
hesitant to to say that that matters is
because i think there's a bigger
geopolitical thing going on uh and it's
not really about um
president biden or hunter bite and
whatever who as you know i've been very
vocal uh about
that story being suppressed so yeah i'm
not persuaded that it's a big deal but
though i don't know enough about it yeah
okay susie says do you believe this move
is likely to put donald trump back in
power
well how could it not
how could it not
people like me and you who did not like
donald trump who did not like his style
who did not like the way he talked he
did not like the the way
the reaction he elicited from the media
much of which by the way in my opinion
was completely inappropriate and unfair
but nonetheless that constant chaos and
warring and and sense of
that he caused yeah or that they caused
in response to him
was so awful yeah and he was really not
good
but
the choice between that
and someone who's actually going to
prevent world war iii
i think is obvious now isn't it um
and you don't think that the the way
that he was so tarnished because of
january 6th yeah
you know everything that happened i mean
the events were dreadful
you don't think that that
has put no no i didn't say that i think
he's he's going to get elected yeah but
i think in a lot of people's minds
they're going to be looking for
a strong man figure yeah now
uh who who is a strong man figure in the
u.s karma harris exactly
you know what i mean yeah so he's an
off-the-shelf solution right there
um
that seems obvious to me
so
yeah i mean i don't see how this doesn't
help him yeah
absolutely and it completely weakens
the democrats
i mean biden's had two disasters in the
space of six months yeah
so uh
we have got uh and
a question here so who said uh
uncle vlad shenanigans is causing a bull
energy market
here with a uh
society prices are right and energy
prices are rising how is this going to
affect society in the world as a whole
well we talked about this earlier the
first thing that people are going to
realize is you need energy security and
it's not just energy security you need
to secure key infrastructure things like
electricity networks things like phone
networks which we [ __ ] sold off to
the chinese and whoever was willing to
buy them uh i imagine uh and if this is
not happening then our government is
deeply irresponsible
and just
uh you know completely incompetent would
say
we've got to make sure that
the chinese the russians and other
strategic adversaries of the us and the
uk
are unable to hurt us when it comes to
energy supplies unable to hurt us when
it comes to supplies of manufactured
goods that we need to survive
are unable to hurt us when it comes to
running our electricity our nuclear
power stations our phone networks our
communications etc we're going to have
to make sure that we're secure because
if you're not secure there's nothing you
can do yeah because someone's got a gun
to your head
so that's that's going to change things
a lot do you think this is going to
focus on mine and increase any and
increase greater cooperation amongst the
west now obviously with brexit
with the with the uk leaving the
european union that created animosity
let's call it what it is
and a sense of disconnect between us and
the rest of europe now that this has
happened
is this good do you think gonna focus on
mine far more and we're actually gonna
start thinking to ourselves you know
what what is the point and having these
petty little squabbles about fish with
france when you've got
putin
invading ukraine
and encroaching further further
westwards
it's a very good question francis but
it's way too soon to tell yeah we don't
know the answer to that question at the
moment
in the spirit of being humble and not
trying to predict things that i don't
know
i i don't have any insight on that
okay but here's a good question and an
important one we just which don't have
an answer yeah because you you hope so
you we really do
uh
this is from alba elf 84 and he says do
you think the west acceptance of kosovo
might be a triggering factor
no it it's an excuse just like iraq it
was a it was not a good decision and it
gave putin a reason to to sort of like
explain why he's entitled to do what
he's doing uh but it's an excuse it's an
excuse you you think yeah yeah you can't
compare kosovo to
russia invading its neighbor and
annexing a piece of its territory it's
not the same as kosovo
galacta watkins ask a very good question
which is
if ukraine
isn't the line in the sand for the west
where do you think and i know it's an
impossible question to ask but where do
you think might be well let's do this
experiment yeah okay okay are you
willing to go and fight and die to
protect the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of lithuania
are you willing to go and fight and die
to defend the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of estonia of latvia of
poland of the czech republic of hungary
of slovakia of slovenia
of romania
are you
well should we go further germany
france
so
you know
i don't know where the line in the sand
is for the west right now the way things
look right now i'd be surprised if
british people would defend britain
i mean have you seen millennials
well you want to put them up against the
russian army yes i do actually yeah yes
sir do i but it wouldn't turn out well
yeah do you know what i mean yeah
and what is a russian army like is it a
well-funded is it by russian standards
it's well funded i i it's by no means
the greatest military in the world at
all
um
the the greatest asset the russian
military has is the one thing that we
lack in the west which means
well it's not men it's the willingness
to have men killed yeah
russian lives don't matter
to
to the people who run russia british
lives matter to the people who run
britain that's the difference yeah so
uh the russian government can send in
200 000 troops and be quite comfortable
to lose 10 20 30 40 50 000. the biggest
weakness of america is not its military
its military is huge by far the biggest
and most powerful in the history of the
world probably bigger and more powerful
than the next 20 nations combined
the the question is how strong is your
military if you are unable to use it
yeah if you lose 10 000 people
and that causes massive social unrest
and disruption
uh
how strong are you
right
how are you going to sell that to your
domestic audience
and vladimir putin doesn't have that
problem yeah
that's the difference right because
there's that saying in world war ii you
know i can't remember you know
i think russia the americans provided
the money england provided the time and
russia provided the blood yeah
yeah
and that attitude has unchanged i mean
the russian world war ii tactics was
essentially just to send soldiers
running at [ __ ] machine guns and just
overwhelm
the germans with
uh with
with bodies yeah that's that's what
particularly in the first phases of the
war that's how it was
later they developed more
powerful tactics but yeah the west
biggest problem is an inability to
to absorb damage
yeah and and the willingness to
sacrifice young it's like a boxer with a
glass jaw like you can punch but if
you're can you take a hit
body god of lies uh says uh lies one
francis using the opportunity to shield
for rejoin
to rejoin the european union
yeah that's why that's what this is all
about me yeah this is what it's all
about juncker and me make best buds
uh
don jones asks why do you think the west
is waking up when canada is becoming
like russia the us has lost all wars
since vietnam why would it fight another
one
what was the first part of the question
so it was like uh why do you think the
west is waking up no i didn't say the
west is waking up i said this is our one
one chance
yeah this is our one chance to to
realize we've been living in a dream
world and wake up
um
if that
[Music]
that happens
great if it doesn't well like i said
like i've been saying for years the west
is over yeah
the west is over anton if we've got any
um emails or paypal could you just uh
send them over please
fantastic so we've got time for a couple
more questions
uh
philip oz is saying
and it's a good question it seems the
media isn't talking much about the
nuclear consequences
why is this and do you think it's
because there are none well i mean
there's obviously like i said we are
closer to nuclear war than we have been
since 1962. i don't think that means
we're close to nuclear war i don't think
we're close to nuclear war at all
um so
i think the media are still trying to
work out what the hell happened this is
blindsided all of them i don't think
they realize what's going on um so yeah
i i don't think i don't think people are
going to understand the full
repercussions of what's happened
probably for years to come
and
a lot of them are just trying to work
out what's going on
and do you think part of that if we talk
about the media for the bit is what's
happened to the media they've
essentially been defunded
you know discredited so you don't have
those
big beast journalists anymore who
actually take the time to understand the
situation read explore spend time in
another country when you've got uh i
know i know it's out of date but a
buzzfeed article you know yeah ten
things about why you should dress like a
hedgehog in bed well you and i have been
warning about the decline of the of the
media environment for a long time yeah
and you're starting to see the the
consequences of that uh just like we
talked about earlier with the caliber of
our politicians it's the same these are
not people who are qualified to be
solving these problems yeah
when our foreign secretary doesn't know
the geography of russia
how are you expecting that person to
negotiate with vladimir putin
that's not going to happen and the same
with the media and the same with
alternative media look at look at all
these influencers running around now
having an opinion about this issue that
they don't understand
uh you know there's go go back a few
days and look at all the articles where
they told you there would be no invasion
no people i wrote a long thread on my
twitter which is uh my pinned post which
you posted on locals there were people
like replying going there will be no
invasion
well how do you know
you don't speak the language you've
never been to this place you don't
understand the geopolitics or the
history
you think that because
matt taibbi or some other idiot told you
right
but these people don't know what they're
talking about
just like this is why i stopped
commenting so much on covet and i've
distanced myself from people who made
the whole
the whole persona
about coven because
i sort of went well you know like yeah
sure i can have an opinion about it but
i don't really know what's going on i'm
not an expert in this i better sort of
just pull back there's there's a lot of
stuff i don't understand
um
and
we don't live in that world we live in a
world where people are incentivized to
comment on things they don't know to
make statements that i never get
verified and that's both mainstream and
alternative media and
all the same people that told you there
would be no invasion they're now either
gonna doub it's interesting watching the
way that this is breaking now because
they're doing one or two things either
they're saying there's no invasion
like the iraqi mist of information do
you remember him what was his name uh
these
see something ali something ali yeah
yeah chemical ally i think chemical yeah
it was a different blog
but whatever uh or they're gonna explain
to you that it's it's justified well
these are you know historical russian
territories if you're just joining us by
the way you can go back and watch the
beginning of the interview we go through
all of this
um
so that's i think that's the other part
of it
we live in exciting times we have got
time for one more
uh
either a super chat or a paypal uh let's
have uh francis we could do an extra 10
minutes if we've got the questions okay
so let's have arvid von brash
and he says i'm not going to do the
accident because that's we'll save that
for harvard yeah it goes do you think
there's anything to the suggestion
that the people running the u.s state
department wanted to bring the ukraine
into nato under clinton
and saw that as unfinished business that
they could finally get done
so well i'm i'm confused
the suggestion that the us department
wanted to bring the ukraine into nato
now yeah
uh
i i doesn't surprise me if the west does
want to bring ukraine into nato yeah no
it doesn't surprise me but uh the
question that you
so let's go back to what we were talking
about just now which is
who do you want to run the world this is
what this conversation is all about
i don't have a problem with western
liberal democracies flawed
and messed up
as they are
asserting their dominance on the world
stage not only do i not have a problem
with that i want them to do that
and this is not some evil imperialist
constantine kissing saying this is just
a pragmatic reality that either we are
expanding or they're expanding that's
the choice so
yes
you could argue that america and the eu
wants to expand eastwards i personally
don't have any problem with that
i don't have any problem with that but
the main reason that it's happening as i
explained before is estonia lithuania
ukraine and others they want to be part
of nato because they know what's coming
they know what happens to people who are
not part of nato that's why they're
desperate they're begging the 2014
revolution in ukraine started because
people thought they were finally going
to move to the west they were going to
join the eu eventually they were going
to join nato and finally they would be
safe from the very thing that's
happening today
from the very tanks that are on their
borders and in their country right now
that's what they wanted they just wanted
their country to be safe from that
that's why nato is expanding that's why
the eu is expanding
they want to take more people in under
this umbrella of western liberal
democracy which is flawed which is not
perfect which has committed many great
evils i agree with you but it's still
better than the alternative hmm
very interesting and very good question
from arvid we'll look forward to seeing
you on raw soon harvard uh this is quite
good actually one from desire brendel
who says can kk please recommend
unbiased sources on the russia ukraine
conflict for people who don't speak
russian
thank you and keep up the good work i
know it's difficult and you can argue
that no one is unbiased and barbara but
some
good caliber resources uh
i don't know his answer i think you
i think
the one thing i would invite everyone to
do is find a good translation of
president putin's speech uh from a
couple of days ago and read that um that
gives you a pretty good
chunk of information that we've covered
here
i i don't think there are unbiased
western resources uh the one thing i
would say is dominic sanbrook dominic
sanbrook who's the co-host of the rest
is history podcast with our former guest
tom holland
he wrote an article in the daily mail
which in my opinion is exactly spot-on
uh so and someone posted it on locals
recently so i would go and find that uh
that is a good start and they also did
an episode of their podcast which talks
about the history of russia and ukraine
which details some of this which if you
want an objective look at the sort of
background to this and that will help
perfect uh this is from steam click greg
gerida
rolls off the tongue
will putin demand a corridor to cannon
grad be next on his list the kaliningrad
absolutely
and look i have no idea what those words
are what they mean where kalining
kaliningrad is well kaliningrad is a
piece of russia that is not connected to
russia
in the same way alaska is not connected
to america yes with a big difference the
america is not going to invade canada to
have access to alaska uh the better
example would be danzig if you remember
that was one of the the demands that
hitler made in the run-up to world war
ii this was a supposedly independent
poor city on the northern uh coast
and he was saying we must be connected
to our to our people in danzig and
that's why he wanted the polish corridor
this is what the question is about of
course he's going to demand that that
will be part of the process of you know
estonia latvia lithuania et cetera and
do you think he's going to get that
no one knows at the moment no no one
knows but you think he's going to demand
i think that is that will be one of the
things that he's he wants to happen now
how the west responds and how ukraine
responds and how this war goes and all
of that will determine the future steps
that's beyond our predictability horizon
do you think one of the solutions should
be unleashing kamala harris on him yeah
i'm sure she'll
just she'll talk him out of it
fantastic so she can be very persuasive
absolutely i think that is pretty much
it let me see if we uh
um
uh to know i think that's pretty much it
all right okay uh
we've answered pretty much all the
questions
thank you so much for joining in we're
hoping to be doing more of these and
with different guests we've done them
with jordan peterson and heather hiring
we've also done it with brett weinstein
and we've also done it with douglas
murray thank you so much for joining in
guys and we will see you very soon with
a raw show
or an episode and they always go out 7pm
uk time take care and see you soon guys